cette semaine le professionnel du cinéma
qui nous donne son coup de cœur c'est
Mariline pou des yeux d'Elsa de
saint-sirlécole
écoutez bonjour ce mois-ci au cinéma Les
Yeux d'Elsa deux événements deux coups
de cœur avec une ciné rencontre autour
du film Une vérité qui dérange une une
ciné rencontre organisée avec
alternatiba et une ciné rencontre
également le 25 novembre avec le film
réparer les vivants le très beau film de
Catel kil veré alors pour le premier
événement une vérité qui dérange avec
alternatiba nous allons recevoir Gill
Ramstein Gill Ramstein qui est un
climatologue et auteur donc c'est
l'occasion de faire le point sur ce film
et sur les
avancées après donc ce documentaire
d'algor qui
était voilà une sorte de plédoyer contre
le réchauffement climatique que donc
l'occasion de faire le point avec Gill
rashtime le 19 novembre c'est notre
survie qui est en jeu
ensuite le deuxème événement c'est le 25
novembre avec réparer les vivants nous
aurons l'occasion de recevoir Pascal
tiieré qui est coordinatrice
hospitalière des prélèvements d'organes
et tissus
pour avoir une réflexion sur ce domaine
un peu particulier scientifique assez
inexploré
un très beau film romanesque danse et
qui montre voilà le le le le transfert
d'organes d'une manière assez étonnante
vivante et très
touchante